look at my face what does this face make
you feel
there's only one right answer fear
that's right
you're scared out of your guy doing mine
i'm the scariest youtuber there is
you don't with me i've exhibited
many times before
my level of threat
but now i've taken it up to another
level baby
night flips everyone yeah before this
video begins
don't do this all right don't cut your
fingers off and then blame pewdiepie
this is not my fault that you're dumb
anyway i'm a fiddly guy
right i like to fiddle with i can't
help it
it's in my blood so i got really into
fiddling with the knife
it's dull by the way like it it's not
gonna hurt anyone
but i love it i'm so into it this is
cool right he's got to look at evil as
possible
i got this oh what is he doing oh spun
it on his thumb
didn't expect that regular flipper
rooney oh
how does he do it it went from fear
to arousal there it is
there it is this is
something satisfying about it right but
let's leave that aside
so i was curious about other knife
flippers
on youtube and i found this video that
is a goddamn masterpiece
ballet song flipping competition with
some of the most hardcore individuals
such as myself all in one spot
baby let's go they flip in the fields
they flip anywhere
my favorite is uh this little kid in the
start so there's this convention i think
it's a competition
actually and i don't know i guess it's
like from movies
you always had the people doing the
sword flips and all that it's like oh
super skilled super
threatening right but then you have this
convention and i think this comment says
it the best i feel so bad but i never
seen people look so geeky and badass at
the same time
the industry's boost the illustrious
squid
that's my man right there this guy you
don't want to mess with this guy look at
that over here
yes let's
[Applause]
[Music]
love it absolutely love it i know it is
a bit cringey to flip a knife
and i think this exhibit it's pretty
well it's funny because like
this could be any convention like an
anime convention just to remove the
change the knives with anime pillars and
you wouldn't know a goddamn difference
look at this dude hell yeah
hell yeah let's go knife flipping it's
cool
don't do this at home don't shoot me
okay
so they have this competition in this
video and i mean
not gonna lie some of them are pretty
[Music]
[Applause]
cool
this guy is a king it looks like
young jim from the office am i right am
i right
first of all shorts amazing it's
supposed to be like a rap battle
where they go off against each other in
the knife flipping and you vote who did
better
and this guy really gets into it he's
like dancing
it's not bad but wait for the finale
it's gorgeous
[Music]
he caught it with its day that just
seems like a terrible idea that's an
awful idea first of all it's not cool
it's lame as hell you could lose your
nuts
what's the point yeah
i caught it with my pee pee yeah
why can you imagine like i kind of get
knife flipping a little bit from the
point of
all right you don't really want to
with someone right it's better to scare
someone off sun tzu
literally said this the best battles are
the ones you can avoid
right i just dropped my name it kind of
makes sense from a
self-defense standpoint but i can you
imagine this guy meets you in the alley
starts flipping catches it with his dick
right between his knights
i'm like i'm out i might sorry
suck and i'm doing it too
god damn it i thought knife flipping was
cool and then i watched this video
and now it's even better i gotta say
though this guy's legit
not this guy really appreciate that like
youtube tutorial background music here
this guy clean dude
[Music]
damn it is this one
hell yeah
[Music]
that's cool love the thumbs up
i'm probably the only one getting a kick
out of this is rna
it's funny all right flying
yeah indiana jones over here
hell yeah three
two grand finals
oh my god it's impossible
whoa okay that was sick
[Music]
like they're summoning a spell or
something
why is this funny i'm trying to figure
out why it's funny it's so
yeah it's just so lame and cool at the
same time it's so good i love it
flipper number one mika
ah he didn't make it to the final the
other guy this
[Music]
he dropped it that's unbelievable i got
gotta love that too you're in a fight
you dropped the knife like hot
shush let me just let me restart gotta
catch it with my crotch
[Music]
dude that guy looks like he's not old
enough to even have a knife what is this
[Music]
america
ah stop
don't do this it's bad those are very
comfortable i love it
feels great in my hand severe adhd
everyone it feels fantastic to have
something
[Music]
you know everyone in this cremation
online
yes you don't with her
no son ah this guy's
garbage
whoa did you see that
hey you sure you want to pick a fight
with me huh
[Music]
sure about this sure you want to
with me
love it i love it are the knives sharp
yes in the competition the host says the
knife must be sharp
why what the what the is this
bro are you saying hey guys what is up
welcome back to another video
i am here with i'm here with my friend
clifton
ella we'll let these kids have knives
what the this is
today i'm going to do my uh update
butterfly collection video
okay that's a trainee thank god okay
they're all trainers thank god i thought
he was using real ones
okay let's talk about this hell yeah
okay butterfly knife uh-huh okay
yeah you can go like this and collect
this and it's open
i think he looks scary dude you're not a
fisherman
you don't have a fish over here your
knife is closed
bang
who cares about how flashy you look
the fishes will be intimidated out of
his mind i mean
you know i knives is he saying that
knife flipping is pointless
[Laughter]
because then i know it's open and what's
the second reason
what happens when you're in a fight yeah
tell it tell us
what happened you shouldn't catch it
with your crotch i've learned that at
least
when you're into a stressful situation
uh-huh come in here you want to do all
this kind of stuff
i'll do it that's great wonderful
wonderful but if you've never been in a
fight
this guy's been in many fights i'm sure
then you never know
how your hands sweat true man this guy
just killed knife luck things
god damn it disrespect them with tricks
after the fight
not before after the fight catches it
with your crotch
ultimate humiliation worse than getting
tea bag all right that's pretty much it
thanks for watching
bye